امتنان امريكيه عن ارسال مقاتلات لوكرانيا
والمانيا تربط المفاوضات مع روسيا
بانسحابها من اوكرانيا
حملات واسع الاعتقال للرجال الدين سنه في
ايران وتحذير من ازمه سوء التغذيه في
البلاد بسبب الغلاء
وقبيل توجهه الى رام الله بل يمكن يلتقي
نظيره الاسرائيلي ويدعو للتهدئه في الضفه
الغربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم اسعد الله صباحكم
نبدا من اخر المستجدات المتعلقه باوكرانيا
حيث اعلن المستشار الالمانيه من البرازيل
اعلن ان انسحاب روسيا من اوكرانيا هو من
اهم شروط المفاوضات
واشار الى ان الشعب الاوكراني لا ينعم
بالسلام وان اثار الحرب الروسيه ليست فقط
في اوكرانيا بل تنعكس على العالم باسره
قبل ذلك اعلن الرئيس الامريكي جو بايد ان
بلاده لن تزود اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف 16
لمساعدتها في التصدي للقوات الروسيه في ما
لم يعطي بيضا للصحفيين اي معلومات عن موعد
زيارته المتوقعه الى بولندا
اما رئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون فقال
اثناء اللقاء جماعه برئيس وزراء هولندا
ماركو ان امر ارسال طائرات مقاتله الى
اوكرانيا غير مستبعد الرئيس الفرنسي اضاف
ان لا شيء ممنوع وان دعم فريسه لاوكرانيا
بالمقاتلات يجب ان لا يضعف الجيش الفرنسي
كما لا ينبغي استخدام الاسلحه التي ترسل
لاوكرانيا في ضرب الاراضي الروسيه
في كيف اكد الرئيس الاوكراني فلود
مارسيلنسكي ان القوات الروسيه تسعى
الانتقام شديد من اوكرانيا كما اعلن
الرئيس زالنسكي بان جيشه يحضر لهجوم مضاد
كبير ضد القوات الروسيه
تريد حقنا الانتقام منا بشده وقد بداوا
ذلك بالفعل اعتقد انهم لن يكونوا قادرين
على تحقيق اي مكاسب ايجابيه لمجتمعهم
وفيما يتعلق بجيشنا فانه سيقف تقدم القوات
الروسيه ويدمرها تدرجيا ونحن نستعد لهجوم
مضاد شامل
هذا ومن المقرر ان يلتقي وزير الخارجيه
المصري سامح شكري خلال زيارته الى موسكو
كلا من وزير الخارجيه روسيا سرجيله بروف
ومسؤولينا اخرين وقال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه ان الوزيره شكري سيناقش مع
المسؤولين الروس مجمله ملفات العلاقات
الثنائيه بين البلدين وتبادل وجهات النظر
حول العديد من الملفات الدوليه والاقليميه
بما في ذلك تطورات اللازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
وتداعياتها المختلفه
في ايران افاد التقارير ان السلطات هناك
تمارس الضغط على رجال الدين السنه في
محافظتي كردستان بلوشستان لارغامهم على
التعاوني معها اعتقلت سلطات الايرانيه
الامنيه الشيخ عبد المجيد مراد زاهي بتهمه
تعكير الصفوه العام والتواصل مع وسائل
الاعلام الاجنبيه وتظليل الراي العام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا ونشره قناه ايران انترناشونال عبر
صفحتها على موقع تويتر نشره ان 7 سجينات
سياسيات ايرانيات في سجن ايفين عرضنا في
رساله مفتوحه عن معارضتهن لاصدار احكام
الاعدام والتهديد بالقتل للسجناء في الحبس
الانفرادي
هذا هو عقب استمرار ارتفاع اسعار المواد
الغذائيه في ايران خلال الشهر الماضي حذرت
وسائل الاعلام من ازمه سوء التغذيه في
البلاد كما توقع برلمانيون ايرانيون
ارتفاع نسبه التضخم الى 60% او اكثر في
الاشهر المقبله
في ايران
احصاءات وزاره الصحه تظهر ان نحو 16% من
الاطفال دون سن السادسه في ايران يعانون
من سوء التغذيه
وان 800 الف طفل في سن النمو يواجهون نقصا
في الطاقه والمواد البروتينيه ونقصا في
المغذيات الدقيقه
[موسيقى]
برلمانيون توقعوا ارتفاع نسبه التضخم الى
اكثر من 60% بحلول مارس المقبل
مركز الاحصاء الايراني اكد ان معدل التضخم
السنوي في البلاد بلغ خلال الشهر الماضي
46.3%
خبراء اقتصاديون ونشطاء نقبيون قدروا ان
معدل التضخم الحقيقي في ايران اعلى بكثير
من احصاءات الحكومه
احداهما على اراضيها في اصفهان واخرى على
الحدود العراقيه السوريه استهدفت ثلاث
غارات قافله شاحنات يرجحها محمله بالاسلحه
في منطقه واقعه تحت سيطره في دير الزور
شرقي سوريا المزيد من التفاصيل مع زميلا
للاختيار
الذي يقال اعداد الشاحنات المستهدفه في
البوكمال ومحتواها لكن الاجماع يتمثل
بضربه اسرائيليه اخرى ساخنه لايران خلال
اقل من ثمان 48 ساعه حيث استهدف الطائرات
مسيره قافله شاحنات في منطقه واقعه تحت
سيطره الميليشيات الايرانيه في دير الزور
شرقي سوريا بعد عبورها من العراق ولم يتضح
بعد من يقف وراء هذا الهجوم العدد المرشع
المرشح للشاحنات المدمره هي ست شاحنات من
اصل 25 استهدفت غرض بالمسيرات والتي تقول
مص سوريا انها اي الشاحنه تحمل في الغالب
اسلحه لامداد مليشيات ايران كون تاثير
الانفجار بعد الضربه كان كبيره القافله
كانت قادمه من ايران مرورا بالعراق
وبحمايه الميليشيات الموليه لايران كاحزب
الله العراقي وفقا للمصادر السوريه وعند
توجه تلك القافله الى سوريا وعبورها
بحمايه الحدث الثوري وميلي هناك توقفت
الشاحنات في قريه الهري بالبكمال السوريه
وهناك تم استهدافها بالمسيرات واوضحت
المصادر ان الغاره الاولى كانت تحذيريه
لكن لم تصب اي شاحنه فيما استهدفت
الغارتان التاليتان تجمع تلك الشاحنات حيث
اصابت الصواريخ شاحنتين بشكل مباشر
واحترقت اربع شاحنات بشكل كامل وللتذكير
مشاهدينا معبر القائم يوصف بالممر
الايراني الذي يؤدي الى كل من لبنان
وسوريا يشهد كثافه عاليه بعمليات تهريب
الاسلحه وايضا البنيه التحذريه لانتاجها
وتجميعها على الاراضي اللبنانيه والسوريه
ورغم الاضرار التي لحقت بمسارات الممر
الجويه والبريه اثر هذه الضربات الجويه
المتكرره الا ان ايران لم تتخلى عنه
بتسهيل من ميليشيات الحجم وحزب الله
العراقي من الجهه العراقيه طبعا وعلى
الجانب السوري تستلم التغطيه عشرات
الميليشيات التابعه للحارس الثوري والتي
تتخذ من البكمال
في هذه النشره ولكن بعد قليل
اشتباكات عنيفه بين مجموعات المسلحه تتبع
لبيبه قرب مطار طرابلس الليبيه
اهلا بكم مجددا اعلن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انه اجرى اجتماعا مثمرا مع
نظيره الاسرائيلي الكوهين قالب يمكن انه
ناقش معك وهين سبل تعزيز العلاقات
الثنائيه والحاجه الى تهدئه الوضع في
الضفه الغربيه من المقرر ان يزوره بلينكن
رام الله اليوم للقاء الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس
التصعيد الحاصل بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين
والملف النووي الايراني شكلات طبق الساخنه
على مائده الحوار بين رئيس الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه وصانعي القرار في اسرائيل
كل ما بيوسعها لمن ايران من امتلاك سلاح
النووي ونحن مصممون على تنفيذ هذه السياسه
في الوقت الذي نجح نتنياهو فيه لسنوات في
تهميش الموضوع
الفلسطينيين رساله لاسرائيل بان توسيع
دائره التطبيع بين اسرائيل ودول المنطقه
وحتى مواجهه ايران باتت مرتبطه بعدم تدمير
حل دولتين
نحن مازلنا نؤمن ونسعى لتنفيذ رؤيه حل
الدولتين وكما قلت لرئيس الوزراء فان اي
شيء يبعدنا عن هذه الرؤيه هو بمفهومنا يمس
بامن اسرائيل على المدى البعيد وبهويتنا
كدوله يهوديه ديمقراطيه
اللافته ان زياره بلنك الى جانب مدير
السياعي الموجود في اسرائيل تزامنت مع شني
ثلاث غارات متفرقه على اهداف داخل ايران
وفي الاقليم طالت القدرات البالستيه وسلاح
المسيره بعيدا عن الكلام الدبلوماسيه
الامريكي والاسرائيلي فان ارث التوتر في
العلاقه بين نتنياهو اداره بايدين يلقي
بظلالها على الحوار الامريكي الاسرائيلي
مع الحكومه الجديده ايضا واشنطن نقلت
قلقها مرتين مرتين من الملف الفلسطينيه
والانفجار الحاصل ومره ثانيه من الملف
الايراني والخشيه من مفاجاه الاسرائيليه
زياد حلبي العربيه القدس الغربيه
اكد نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه ميخائيل
في لقاء مع نائب وزير الخارجيه السوريه
ايمن سوستاني استعداد موسكو للمساعده في
تطبيع العلاقات بين دمشق وانقره على اساسي
مبادئ احترام السياده السوريه الخارجيه
الروسيه شددت ايضا خلال الاجتماع على
القضايا الموضوعيه لزياده تعزيز العلاقات
التقليديه الروسيه السوريه بما في ذلك
جدول الاتصالات الثنائيه على مختلف
المستويات
افاد اعلام الليبي وقوع اشتباكات بين
مجموعات المسلحه بمحيط مطار طرابلس وذكرت
المصادر ان المجموعات تتبع وزاره الداخليه
والدفاع في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه التي
يراسها عبد الحميد بيبه وانها تستهدف
السيطره على المنطقه
هدد المجلس الاعلى لقبائل ليبيا باغلاق
حقول النفط والغاز في شرق البلاد بعد
اتفاق حكومه الدبيبه مع ايطاليا مجلس
القضاء الوصفه الاتفاق مع روما بغير
الشرعي مشيرا الى ان الاحتقان في الشارع
الليبي وصل الى درجه غير مسبوقه
في الرباط عقد وزير الخارجيه المغربيه
النصر بوريطه اول محادثات ثنائيه
دبلوماسيه مع عبد الله باتيلي رئيسه بعثه
الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا
مع عبد الله باتيلي رئيسي بعثه الامم
المتحده للدعم في ليبيا اعلن ناصر بوريطه
وزير الخارجيه المغربي ان الامم المتحده
هي التي يمكنها حصريا ايجاد حل في ليبيا
بعيدا عن التدخلات الاجنبيه
واحده ليبيا الوطنيه مع سيادتها الترابيه
حل اييه في اطار سياده ليبيا وحدتها
الترابيه وحدتها الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
لرئيس بعثه الامم المتحده في ليبيا من
الرباط دعوه الى الليبيين من اجل الحوار
تحتاج ليبيا الى الاستقرار بعد 10 سنوات
من الصراع فمن مصلحه الليبيين الليبيون
يعبرون عن هذا بطريقه قويه ويريدون مؤسسات
مستقره وذات شرعيه تفتح الطريقه امام
الازدهار في بلدهم
تشديد المغربي على البقاء دائما على مسافه
واحده من الاطراف فيما ترى بعثه الامم
المتحده للدعم في ليبيا ان الشرعيه في هذا
البلد لا يمكن حلها الا عبر انتخابات
رئاسيه وبرلمانيه بعثته الامم المتحده
للدعم في ليبيا مع رئيسها الجديد تعتبر
المغرب احد الشركاء الدوليين في الملا في
ليبيا فيما الرباط ترى بعثه الامم المتحده
للدعم في ليبيا مظله لما سارين اثنين
احتضنهما المغرب حول الا في الليبيه مسارس
خيرات ومسار بوزنيقه عادل الزبير العربي
الرباط
الى اليمن حيث تمارس الميليشيات الحوثيه
انتهاكات جسيمه بحق الاطفال في تعز ما
تسبب باعاقات دائمه للعشرات متابعه
الى حيث يلعب الاطفال لكنهم يعودان الى
المنزل خائبين دون ان تلامس الكره القدم
احدهم على هذا الحال يوميا وبوجه تملاه
الحسره يتجرع الطفل بدر وشقيقه قسوه
الحياه منذ ان بترت قدم بدر حوثيين بلغته
في حي المطار القديم غربي المدينه
عشان البنات حياتنا
كده ولا ولا تجرح مع اصحابنا ولا ندخل
الجنه
[موسيقى]
التي تسكن الخيه
يعني
الطريق
لكن استمرت جماعه الحوثي في استهداف
المدنيين والاطفال بشكل خاص الاطفال
النساء
على المدينه مارست الميليشيات الحوتيه
انتهاكات جسيمه بحق الاطفال تشور احصائيات
الى ان اكثر من 250 طفلا في تعز يعانون من
الاعاقه نتيجه الحرب الحوثيه غالبيتهم لا
يزالون يخضعون لجلسات علاج طبيعي في مركز
الاطراف الصناعيه بمستشفى الثوره بتعز
تعتزم اذن الميليشيات الحوثيه ان تجعل
الكثير من ابناء المدينه هذه يعيشون في
اعاقه دائما خصوصا الاطفال والنساء الذين
تستهدفهم الى الاحياء السكنيه والطرقات
بالقضاء في والغام الارضيه ال سعيد
العربيه تعز
في باكستان اعلنت مصادر طبيه قبل قليل
الارتفاع حصيله ضحايا تفجير بمسجد للشرطه
في بيشاور شمال غربيه البلاد الى 83 قتيلا
وذلك بعد وصول المزيد من الجثث ولم تعلن
اي جهه المسؤوليتها عن الهجوم نتابعه
هجوم الارهابيين
يتمكن من تجاوز الخطوط الامنيه سكنيه
كانتي نيو من الجيش
تم انتشاله ثماني عشره جثه وثلاثه جرحى او
لا يزال هناك على الاقل شخصان على قيد
الحياه وربما عدد اخر من القتلى قد يستغرق
اخراجه من تحت الارقام
باكستان مسؤوليتها عن الهجوم الا ان
الهجوم الذي اعتبر الاكثر دمويه منذ نحو
عام عاد الى الاذهان مشاهد الدماء والدمار
التي شهدتها البلاد خلال العقدين
السياسيين والعسكريين في وقت تعاني فيه
البلاد وانقساما سياسيا وازمه اقتصاديه
مسجد
الامن وقتل الاب ونحن مستعدون للتضحيه
لاجل ذلك
في وقت صعدت فيه جماعات ارهابيه وانفصاليه
هجماتها لعل من ابرزها حركه طالبان
باكستان التي اعلنت انسحابها من هدنه هشه
مع الحكومه شهرا نوفمبر الماضي تزامن ذلك
مع شني اجهزه الامن عند تحملات امنيه
اسفلت عن مقتل واعتقال العشرات من
المسلحين
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه يرى مراقبون انه هجوم
بشاور يطرح تساؤلات عده حول نجاعه
الاجراءات الامنيه ويجدد على ان الملف
الامني يظل من ابرز التحديات التي تواجهها
الحكومات الباكستانيه المتعاقبه عبد
الرحمن العربيه بشاور
مشاهدينا دعونا ننقل لكم هذه الصور
المباشره التي تاتينا الان لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويدا اوستن والذي يصل العاصمه
الكوريه الجنوبيه سيول
قال قبل وصوله ان الولايات المتحده وكوريا
الجنوبيه ستجريان تدريبات نظريه لتعزيز
الردع ضد التهديدات النوويه وايضا اضافه
في مقال بعنوان التحالف يقف على اهبه
الاستعداد نشرته وكاله الانهاب للانباء
قال ان واشنطن وسيول ستجريان تدريبات
نظريه حيث تتم مناقشته سيناريوهات معقده
تركز على التهديدات النوويه في شبه
الجزيره الكوريه قصدي ان يزور سيول للمره
الثالثه طبعا بصفته وزيرا للدفاع ومن
المقرر ان يلتقي نظيره الكوري الجنوبي
الرئيس يوم سوق يونس
طبعا ياتي هذا في ظل تصاعد التوتر ما بين
كوريا الشماليه وكوريا
الجنوبيه وطبعا اطلاق كوريا الشماليه عدد
من الصواريخ اا فيما اعتبر على مستوى
المجتمع الدولي وايضا
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه على انه
تهديد
لمنطقه الولايات المتحده في اكثر من مره
واخرها هذه الزياره الان وهذه المناورات
التي تجري تاكد دائما دعمها لكوريا
الجنوبيه في مواجهه اي تهديد من كوريا
الشماليه اذا هذا وصول لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي لكوريا الجنوبيه في رساله واضحه
الى كوريا الشماليه واي تهديد همم كان من
تلك المنطقه
[موسيقى]
تستعد فرنسا اليوم جديد من الاحتجاجات ضد
اصلاحات اقتراحها الرئيس امانويل ماكرون
وعلى راسها رفع سن التقاعد من 62 الى 64
عاما تعمل النقابات ان يكون التحرك الجديد
بالزخم نفسه الذي شهدته احتجاجات الخميس
الاسود في التاسعه عشر من هذا الشهر اذا
افاد مصدرهم في الشرطه ان القوات الام
تتوقعوا حشودا ممثله في 240 مظاهره في كل
انحاء البلاد
اطلقت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه خدمه اصدار
تاشيره المرور للزياره للقادمين جوا بشكل
الكتروني وذلك بهدف تسهيل الاجراءات حيث
ستسمح تاشيره المرور بالدخول الى السعوديه
واداء العمره والتنقل في كافه المناطق
واضافت الوزراء ان القرار دخل حيز التنفيذ
بدءا من امس وذلك عبر التقدم بطلب الزياره
جوا عبر منصات الخطوط الجويه السعوديه
وطيران الناس
الى العناوين
امريكيه عن ارسال مقاتلات لاوكرانيا
والمانيا تربط المفاوضات مع روسيا
بانسحابها من اوكرانيا
حملات واسعه لاعتقال رجال الدين سنه في
ايران وتحذير من ازمه السوء تغذيه في
البلاد بسبب الغلاء
قبيله توجهه الى رام الله بلنكن يلتقي
نظيره الاسرائيلي ويدعو للتهدئه في الضفه
الغربيه
نلتقي بعد دقائق ونشره جديده مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]